i know can we talk about the japanese
branches oh my god
they're like okay not not just the
japanese breakfast very specifically
the uh but that is the traditional
japanese
traditional japanese my first time
hearing this was chris broad saying
don't ever like ask for the japanese
breakfast
yeah [ __ ] i thought oh he's just being
pessimistic chris right yeah
i was a fool i should have listened to
you chris it's [ __ ] garbage
okay it's not it's okay no i think the
problem is that it's the complete
opposite of garbage it's too much
it's too good it's there's like you you
get about like 50 different dishes i
swear to god and i'm just like
dude it's breakfast just just give me
like just give me a bowl it's like a
worthy contender with an american
breakfast right where it's just like
that's just too much food i don't know
it's actually even more than
it's way more than an american breakfast
is yeah because there's
there's like with an american breakfast
you can fit everything on one [ __ ]
plate at least yeah with like japanese
breakfast you have
you have like it covers it covers this
entire table
right and then as you're eating they
bring out like more dishes
like more small dishes in between like
the fish
the tofu the soup the uh
i can't even name it it'll be like a
there'll be like a salad there'll be
like a potato that's been marinated in
like a different [ __ ] way i don't
know yeah
like two different types of salad
probably a plate of just
single tiny things that you've got no
idea what the [ __ ] they are they're
probably going to be radish because
every single everything seems to be
radish like everything is a [ __ ]
radish
every time every time i see a japanese
breakfast in front of me i'm like why am
i eating an art exhibition
you know that's that's just what it
feels like it's just like this looks
really pretty
it looks really pretty but man i'm for
one i've never finished a japanese
breakfast then rice as well they give
you rice of course
yeah they give you rice i'm like this
this is like this is like a
five course meal that i'm having just as
i've woken up and
i never ever finished a japanese
breakfast yeah i don't mind the fish
that the the cooked mackerel they
normally bring you i don't mind that
cook
mackerel doesn't really taste like
anything it's like it's a mackerel i
don't know about that
i disagree about it yeah macro has
probably like the most tasty
it's my favorite mackerel but like it's
just so clean like you never get any
light there's no aftertaste to mackerel
it's just a pure it's like the chicken
no i got an aftertaste of the mouth
mackerel is the chicken of fish nah
that's fine
salmon is the chicken fish
you can do so much with salmon people do
do some pork
that's the chicken that's the chicken
mackerel is just salmon with attitude
oh i'm recalling all the food items that
might make you they probably give you
eggs but then you know you'd probably
want like
fried egg scrambled eggs yeah maybe a
poached egg yeah they give you like some
[ __ ] egg roll that's been rolled up
and steamed and i'm like
yeah and it's it's [ __ ] cold and i'm
like why is it cold
give me a hot egg please most of the
dishes are actually cooked they're all
cold and
i don't know if this is like a western
thing but like i want certain heart to
wake me up and
the worst part is right is that you're
doing you're eating this and you're like
yeah it's filling and
something's missing can i have coffee
perhaps
do they have a cough and espresso
machine back there please just i bring
my own pods i don't care just
give me a [ __ ] coffee please well
that's what the green tea is for right
it's the hot green tea
it's that that's the hot that's the only
heat you're gonna get out of a japanese
breakfast or the miso soup
i would kill for a coffee man and even
when you get like your japanese friends
sometimes they're like man i just
i just want japanese japanese breakfast
like way too extra for my own liking
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
but i mean i guess that's why you know
it's a it's a very infrequent occurrence
right yeah it's it's that special thing
yeah if you go to a hotel it's going to
be the shitty continental breakfast that
you reluctantly eat because you
you know you don't really have as much
choice oh my god those are depressing
i don't know i like that for like the
first two days
because i don't know like it's it's just
it's just a recognizable meal and you
have it for two days and afterwards
you're just like okay this is getting
really boring now and i want something
different yeah